SEE THE DEEP STATE CORRUPTION OF
CLOSE AND PERSONAL.
COME 2020, THE CHOICE WILL NOT
BE CLEAR.
JOINING US THE, NORTH CAROLINA
MARK MEADOWS, FLORIDA
CONGRESSMAN MATT GAETZ.
THANKFULLY THE ONE GROUP IN
CONGRESS THAT KEEPS THEIR
PROMISES, STANDS FOR PRINCIPALS,
THE FREEDOM CONGRESS.
CONGRESSMAN MEADOWS, LET ME
BEGIN WITH YOU.
FIRST, LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
MEANING OF GETTING BAGHDADI, BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY, REPUBLICANS
EVEN CRITICAL OF THE PRESIDENT'S
POLICY IN SYRIA, BUT IT'S THIS
PRESIDENT THAT TOOK AWAY THE
RULES OF ENGAGEMENT AND BEAT THE
CALIPHATE COMPLETELY IN SYRIA.
NOW THEY'VE GOT ITS LEADER, THE
LEADER OF ISIS.
>> IT WAS A GOOD DAY FOR
AMERICA, IT'S A GOOD DAY OF THE
FREE WORLD, AND A GOOD DAY FOR
THE PRESIDENT AND HIS
DECISIVENESS OF TAKING OUT NOT
JUST THE NUMBER ONE GUY, BUT THE
JUST THE NUMBER ONE GUY, BUT THN
JUST THE NUMBER ONE GUY, BUT THM
JUST THE NUMBER ONE GUY, BUT THE
JUST THE NUMBER ONE GUY, BUT THR
JUST THE NUMBER ONE GUY, BUT THO
JUST THE NUMBER ONE GUY, BUT THE
JUST THE NUMBER ONE GUY, BUT THA
JUST THE NUMBER ONE GUY, BUT THD
JUST THE NUMBER ONE GUY, BUT THN
JUST THE NUMBER ONE GUY, BUT THM
JUST THE NUMBER ONE GUY, BUT THE
JUST THE NUMBER ONE GUY, BUT THR
TWO GUY IN TERMS OF ACTIVITIES
IN SYRIA.
YOU CAN CRITICIZE THE PRESIDENT
FOR HIS SYRIA POLICY, BUT LET ME
TELL YOU, IT LOOKS PRETTY GOOD
ON MONDAY AFTER THE WEEKEND IN
TERMS OF NOT ONLY ARE WE
PROTECTING THE OIL FIELDS, BUT
WE ARE GOING AFTER TERRORISTS.
THE PICTURES YOU SHOWED EARLIER,
THE BEHEADINGS AND ALL THE
THINGS THAT WE CAN REMEMBER
THAT.
THAT WAS IN OUR LIVING ROOMS AND
YET IT HAS NOT BEEN A COMMON
OCCURRENCE SINCE THIS PRESIDENT
HAS BEEN IN OFFICE.
I'D LIKE TO THINK THE PRESIDENT
FOR HIS DECISIVENESS.
>> Sean: MATT GAETZ, WE GO TO
THE WITCH HUNT.
I'VE WRITTEN THIS PROGRAM AGAIN
AND AGAIN, "POLITICAL," THEY
CONFIRMED IN FACT THERE WORDS IN
ELECTION INTERFERENCE BY UKRAIN
UKRAINE.
WE READ ABOUT THE DANGERS OF
FOREIGN INTERFERENCE IN OUR
ELECTION.
WE HAVE A COUNTRY ADMITTING IT.
YOU'VE GOT A VICE PRESIDENT AT
THE TIME BRAGGING ABOUT
LEVERAGING OUR TAX MONEY TO GET
A UKRAINIAN PROSECUTOR FIRED AND
WE FOUND OUT WHAT'S PAYING HIS
WHOLE SON MILLIONS WITH NO
EXPERIENCE IN UKRAINE, ENERGY,
OR GAS.
WHY WOULD THEY BE PAYING UNDER
BITE AND ALL THAT MONEY WITH
ZERO EXPERIENCE PLEASE MAKE
YOU'D LIKE TO BE PAID THAT MONEY
KNOWING NOTHING.
>> I HOPE I KNOW A LITTLE MORE
THAN NOTHING, BUT HUNTER BIDEN
IS NOT THE GUY YOU EXPECT TO GO
AND RESOLVE INTERNATIONAL
DISPUTES.
ACCORDING TO REPORTING BY THE
NEW YORKER, HE HASN'T RESOLVED
HIS OWN DISPUTE WITH HERTZ
RENTAL CAR FOR LEAVING A CRACK
PIPE IN A CRASH VEHICLE.
NOT AN INTERNATIONAL MAN OF
MYSTERY.
WHAT YOU SEE IS DONALD TRUMP IS
INNOCENT AND THE DEEP STATE IS
GUILTY.
WHEN YOU GOT MR. DURHAM OUT
THERE WITH AN INVESTIGATION THAT
TRANSITION FROM AN
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW TO A
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION, THAT WAS
A HAT TIP, AND CATALYZING EVENT
AT THAT BECAUSE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND MR. DURHAM
TO SEEK THE ABILITY TO HAVE THE
CRIMINAL PROCESS AT THEIR
DISPOSAL.
I ALSO THINK DURHAM PROBABLY
THREATENS THE DEEP STATE A LOT
MORE THAN EVEN THE FISA REVIEW
BECAUSE THE DURHAM INVESTIGATION
IS THE INVESTIGATION ECHOES
DEEPEST INTO THE OBAMA
WHITE HOUSE AND THAT'S WHY I
THINK YOU'LL SEE PEOPLE LIKE
CLAPPER AND BRENNAN IMPLICATED.
>> Sean: YOU SEE THEY ARE
TRYING TO GET OUT AHEAD OF THE
STORY.
YOU SEE WITH STEELE YOU CAN HAVE
YOU SEE WITH STEELE YOU CAN HAVA
YOU SEE WITH STEELE YOU CAN HAVC
YOU SEE WITH STEELE YOU CAN HAVU
YOU SEE WITH STEELE YOU CAN HAVT
YOU SEE WITH STEELE YOU CAN HAVR
YOU SEE WITH STEELE YOU CAN HAVN
YOU SEE WITH STEELE YOU CAN HAVE
YOU SEE WITH STEELE YOU CAN HAVL
YOU SEE WITH STEELE YOU CAN HAVG
YOU SEE WITH STEELE YOU CAN HAVN
YOU SEE WITH STEELE YOU CAN HAVE
INVESTIGATION WITHOUT THE
PRESIDENT KNOWING.
THAT PRESIDENT WOULD BE OBAMA.
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT HE KNEW AND
WHEN HE KNEW IT.
LET ME ASK YOU THIS, CONGRESSMAN
MEADOWS, WE'VE GOT THE IG REPORT
COMING OUT.
ON THE HEELS OF THAT, WE ARE
GOING TO GET THE DURHAM REPORT.
WHAT ARE YOU EXPECTING AMERICANS
ARE GOING TO HEAR AND HOW
SHOCKED WILL THEY BE AT THEIR
FINDINGS?
>> I THINK THE FINDINGS WILL BE
BREATHTAKING.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT MANY OF THE
ALLEGATIONS THAT THE PRESIDENT
HAS MADE OVER THE LAST THREE
YEARS AND THE GENESIS OF THIS
WHOLE INVESTIGATE THE
INVESTIGATOR PROCESS WILL
ACTUALLY PROVIDE FRUIT WHERE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE STARTING TO
SAY, NOT ONLY WAS THE
PRESIDENT'S CAMPAIGN SPIED UPON,
BUT THEN THERE WAS A COVERT
OPERATION TO TRY TO COVER THIS
UP.
YOU MENTIONED ONE THING EARLIER,
SEAN, THAT WAS ABOUT UKRAINE AND
YOU TALKED ABOUT A POLITICO
ARTICLE, BUT WE GOT BETTER
EVIDENCE THAN THAT, WE'VE GOT
CONGRESSIONAL TRANSCRIPTS OF
NELLIE OHR WHICH INDICATED THE
ONLY CONNECTION TO SOME OF HER
SOURCES WAS LUSHENKO FROM
UKRAINE!
OF ADAM SCHIFF WANT TO GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF THIS, THE
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN INNOCENT.
EIGHT WITNESSES, 60 HOURS.
THE PRESIDENT IS INNOCENT.
WE NEED TO SHUT THIS DOWN.
BUT WE DO NEED TO INVESTIGATE
THE ORIGINS AND THERE IS A
UKRAINE PROBLEM, IT'S A UKRAINE
PROBLEM WITH THE DEMOCRATS.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT WAS
ASKING TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
THE INTERFERENCE AND ALL THESE
PEOPLE THOUGHT -- TOLD US, WE
NEED TO CARE ABOUT THIS FOR
THREE YEARS.
LAST WORD, MATT GAETZ.
YOU'VE GOT ABOUT 20 SECONDS.
>> THE STRONG AS EVIDENCE FOR ME
THAT UKRAINE WAS INVOLVED IS
FROM A COURT IN THE UKRAINE.
A COURT IN THE UKRAINE FOUND
THAT THERE WERE IMPROPER ACTIONS
BY THE UKRAINE TO GET INVOLVED.
>> Sean: CAUGHT IN UKRAINE,
DETERMINED THAT ELECTION
INTERFERENCE TOOK PLACE.
HAVE THEIR COUNTRY AGAINST OUR
ELECTIONS.